touch my hand kyrie we like you tonight
we'll throw a bottle at you but you know
iverson why must you pit man against
fellow man
through a portal
is this an illusion but isn't reality
its own illusion
yo what
oh hell yeah is this the club welcome to
the arena outside it's space and time we
have 2001 allen iverson fresh off his
last chance to win a championship versus
harry irvin who still hasn't imploded
the next today we determine who is
powerful the most excuse me how is this
happening it's an arena outside of space
and time we're not the singularity so
don't worry about it okay where was i
play to 11 win by two all right watch
your ankles
[Applause]
are we one consciousness or have we won
consciousness
[Applause]
what a crossover is that legal that's a
carry but if we have the power of time
control why are we using it for
basketball debates iverson does his
crossover yet again
but hey i guess it works maybe it's
artificial intelligence ai
[Music]
you're the answer and i'm
the question bro that's corny as hell
are we sure that's right they never
showed that part on youtube to gain the
answers i must beat the answer
[Music]
all right bro we get it i'm a huge
influence on
kyrie scores
[Applause]
yo can y'all just shut up so we can play
oh cookies
bro i haven't been listening to the
thing any of y'all have said and iverson
seems to be delaying the inevitable
[ __ ] with it
game point
save that loose [ __ ] man
only cuz he got the ball first
man forget that noise remember take time
for yourself you're right i'm going to
skip the next couple of games whoa not a
game i was talking about
[Applause]
boo practice the portal for mj vs lebron
you cowards shh keep subscribing and
eventually it'll happen shut up
[Music]
oh god she's juggling too many timelines
this cannot be safe
[Applause]